I tried to fight Rogan last week really
whoops oh that picture wasn't
photoshopped the the what no he ripped
my shoulder off wait really yeah and I
was hammered so I was like you can't tap
me dude you just who's gay I kept
[__] with him he taught me like eight
times dude he kept that easy yeah do you
think if you were sober and he was sober
that you could wrestle at least no no no
well he also does the kickboxing
her leg Yeah immediately and Ari was
[__] with him while he was doing it
oh he was gassing him up Ari was like
Shane you're so much stronger than him
just stand up yeah that's what I'm
saying he's like no he's not it's like
dude he's [__] with you stop
ah
[Laughter]
wow